Welcome to everybody. We're delighted to have you here for this session.
It's a beautiful day outside,
and
reinforcing to our goal of keeping people healthy and preventing
cancers
as a supplement to the
much larger effort on treating cancers after they've already occurred, of
course.
This is the science and health policy session on cancer
prevention and screening for early-stage disease.
I'm Gil Omenn from the University of Michigan and our Rogel Cancer Center.
In this session, we bring together science, medicine, public health, and health
policy
to focus on a shared challenge: reduce the incidence and mortality
of cancers.
My disclosures are simple. I'm on several
small, still early-stage companies from the University of Michigan,
basically.
There is a great opportunity to reduce the cancer burden
in the United States and around the world.
Cancers are leading causes of global morbidity and mortality.
The message here is that incidence is largely attributable
to modifiable risk factors. About 40% of
cancer cases worldwide are preventable, according to the
IARC, International Agency for Research on Cancer,
the "Nature Medicine" 2026 paper recently published.
Globally, nearly half of preventable cancer cases involve lung,
stomach, and cervix.
The two leading contributors, of course, are by far smoking
and then nine different viral infections
with the other conditions well known to you listed here.
Environmental includes 13 different occupational exposures
monitored by IARC.
Cancer mortality can be reduced by prevention,
by screening for early detection,
sometimes called interception, which is to capture a
precancerous lesion before it becomes malignant,
and of course, progress in treatment as well.
Prevention and screening were responsible for 80%
of the deaths averted
in the
long period from 1975 to 2020.
Estimates in 2023 of the percent of US population
that are up to date on
recommended cancer screening
shows 80% for breast cancer screening, that's mammography,
76% for cervical cancer,
64%, may be rising still, for
colorectal.
You can see all of those
in this slide here to the right.
So breast has been moving up nicely and now been level for
25 years to almost 30 years.
Colorectal continues to rise and is continuing further.
But lung cancer screening, for which there's quite a large literature,
is extremely low. We're going to hear about that in detail from Dr.
Wood.
Only 14% of cancers are currently detected through these
recommended screening tests in the US.
There is ample room for making a lot of progress.
Gaps in cancer screening affected by age-related guidelines,
which are in some flux,
insurance status,
race, and socioeconomic
status.
There's a particular approach to mention here developed at the University of
Michigan, my colleagues Mark Fendrick and others,
called value-based insurance design,
where the out-of-pocket expenses for medical services
are reduced as much as possible, even turned negative.
That say, pay the patient to do certain things we think
have such a big payoff for them and for society that we
need to encourage them further to take advantage of advances from research,
and charge more for things we're trying to discourage.
Medicaid eligibility restrictions
and the FY25 Appropriations Act, of course, are in the
opposite direction,
leading to an estimated million missed cancer screenings
and clinical preventive services over the next two years.
So the policy opportunities include more tobacco
regulation,
more community-level personalized interventions, including
perhaps selected genetic testing, as we'll hear from Dr.
Rebick,
screening access for rural and underserved populations,
and barriers to drug development.
There's a vast effort going on in anti-cancer
drug development,
and we could make a lot of progress, I still hope,
for chemoprevention
at early stages and at pre-malignant stages.
To give you some idea how this was viewed 45 years ago,
we organized, my colleagues and I around the country,
the CARROT trial, beta carotene and retinol efficacy trial.
You see the details here, 18,000 high-risk smokers, former smokers,
and asbestos-exposed shipyard workers.
The results, this was a time when cereal boxes said, "Laced with
beta carotene," minus the laced.
Contains beta carotene.And the
vitamin supplement crowd was very keen about this.
We thought it was good epidemiological association basis for
starting the trial, as did the NCI.
But the result was 28% more lung cancer, 17% more
lung cancer mortality, 26% more cardiovascular
mortality.
And if that might have left you quizzical, a
simultaneous study in Finland with vitamin E and beta carotene,
alpha-tocopherol and beta carotene, so ATBC,
had similar results.
Our goals today are to outline policy strategies to reduce
major cancer risk factors, to explore innovative
cancer prevention methods, hopefully including chemoprevention,
discuss policy approaches to improving uptake of recommended
screenings,
highlight community and behavioral interventions, and promote
policy mechanisms that can address disparities.
Our session has a wonderful group of panelists.
I'm delighted to be part of this panel with them,
and the names are all shown here. I will start with Dr.
Suchitra Krishnan-Sarin from Yale Department of
Psychiatry.
Welcome.
Thank you.
Do I just click to move ahead? Is that the...
Right arrow.
Ah, right arrow. Got it.
Okay. Well, thank you for inviting me to speak at this very
important
panel. I'm going to take you through a whirlwind about tobacco
regulation and interventions, but I'm happy to answer any questions at
the end that you might have.
I do not have any disclosures. My work is funded by the FDA and NIH,
so anything that I say today are my own views and do not represent their
official views.
So to start out, I know I'm preaching to the choir here, and you've already heard
tobacco is the leading cause of cancer.
Roughly 80% of lung cancers and many other cancers.
Oral cancer from smokeless tobacco use is very common, and it also
causes diseases in many other organs.
Now, if anybody is interested, this is a really nice schema that is
presented in this paper on the relationship between smokeless tobacco use
and cigarette smoking and the different mechanisms by which it causes cancer, and I
would encourage you to take a look at it.
So these are cigarette and cigar prevalence rates, and I have to say, in the US, we
have been doing pretty good. We are on a downward trend.
You see the rates decreasing. We are headed towards the Healthy People
2030 goal of 5%, and I hope we reach it.
But we are headed in the right direction.
And on the right panel, you see cigar use rates, which have remained pretty
flat.
This is smokeless tobacco use. This is very localized.
Certain states have more smokeless tobacco use than other states, but it's
also kind of remained flat. And then on the right side, you see
e-cigarette use. E-cigarettes appeared on the market around 2009,
and we started monitoring their use since then, and you can see a steady increase
in use of these products.
This is not a US problem. It's a global problem.
Globally, the rates of use of cigarette is much higher in many other
countries and regions,
and they are all decreasing except for certain regions that you can see here, like
the Eastern Mediterranean and Western Pacific, which is actually going up.
Okay, so I'm going to switch now. Every country I showed you has their own set of
regulations around tobacco. I'm going to switch and tell you about what we have
been doing in the US all these years.
We've, I think, had a phenomenal set of regulations over the
past
many years, starting in the 1900s and so on, which
have addressed tobacco use, especially cigarette use, including things
like broadcast ad bans and cigarette taxes, which have really helped to decrease
the use of cigarettes. Now, the most
recent entrant into this is the Family Smoking Prevention and Tobacco
Control Act, which was signed by President Obama into
law in 2009. This, for the first time, gave the
FDA the authority to regulate tobacco products and
nicotine products. Now, I want to give you some brief
information on how this differs from the FDA's ability to
regulate drugs. Drugs, as you know, are approved by a safe and effective
standard. So is the drug safe? Does it have an efficacy in a particular condition?
As opposed to the Center for Tobacco Products in FDA regulates tobacco
products by a public health standard.
So is the presence of these products in the market good for all of
public health? And they do this through two routes specified on the
right side. They give marketing approval called Pre-market,
PMTAs, or they give a modified tobacco risk approval,
which basically means that the product has a reduced risk compared to other
products in the market. Most of the tobacco companies today get
marketing approval, which basically allows them to market the product in the US.
These are all the tobacco products regulated by the US FDA.
You see some familiar faces here. Some new ones like the oral nicotine
pouches and these heat sticks, which you're going to see a lot on the market very
soon, which are products which burn tobacco at a lower temperature
than cigarettes and therefore presumably produce less carcinogens.
Now, I'm going to use e-cigarettes as an example of how the FDA does this work.
So,
e-cigarettes, as you know, came on the market in 2009.
On the left side, you see a whole list of products which have
actually received marketing approval from the FDA.
But despite this, there is a huge unauthorized product
market. You get a lot of products which are not approved by the FDA in any
way, and there are also constantly emerging novel products like
e-cigarettes with video games in them, or these other products which
blatantly challenge FDA regulations because they say they don't contain
nicotine, but they contain an analog of nicotine called metatine, and
therefore they are not subject to the same kind of
regulation.The concerns with these kind of
unregulated market is youth appeal, obviously.
This figure shows you how youth use of cigarettes went up
significantly after Juul first appeared on the market around 2014, 2015.
And then we have fortunately had a lot of regulations which have brought youth use
down. There is a lot of concern about health outcomes related to
e-cigarettes. This literature is just emerging.
I would encourage you to take a look at this review paper, which just came out,
which points out that the potential for carcinogenesis from e-cigarettes is not
just nicotine, but all the other constituents of the e-cigarette, which can be
related to DNA damage and inflammation.
But e-cigarettes also have benefit.
There are good clinical trials, and there is a Cochrane review which shows that
e-cigarettes do help smokers quit smoking,
and they are relatively safe. So when the FDA considers a product like this, they
have to do a risk-benefit assessment.
On the right side, you have it could help cigarette smokers quit.
It could reduce disease risk and morbidity.
But on the other hand, you have to consider the harms.
It could lead to initiation of nicotine use and addiction, or in adults, very
commonly, we see a lot of dual use, where many adult smokers don't
necessarily quit cigarettes but use e-cigarettes and cigarettes along
with each other at the same time.
So what can we do? Last few slides.
I would suggest we should all really go back and follow the treatment
guidelines that we have. The WHO came out with a great set of
guidelines in 2024, which recommended that all healthcare
facilities should include an assessment of tobacco use status and use
of tobacco interventions. They recommended training all healthcare providers
on delivery of evidence-based interventions and provide them at low
or reduced costs. So we definitely need to consider this.
They also provided guidelines for what you could use.
There are many guidelines for how brief interventions work.
Even something as short as 30 seconds to three minutes can have an impact on a
person's motivation to quit.
And of course, more intensive support for those who need it.
And the WHO recommends varenicline or Chantix, nicotine replacement
therapy, bupropion, and cytisine, which is a nicotine analog, as
adjuncts for smoking cessation.
But I want to point out that there are still huge disparities
in terms of access to treatment, in terms of whether people use
interventions or not. On this slide, you see that almost any smoker you
talk to will say they want to quit smoking, and that's what the extreme left
bars show you on all these figures. But look at the bars in the center.
Very few of them actually manage to quit, and that is partly because
if you keep moving along the right side of this figure, you can see that
the number receiving quit assistance and the number that actually use counseling or
medication goes down dramatically.
And this is particularly the case in Black or African American
communities and in Hispanic communities.
So we really need to do better because our interventions are
not reaching many communities.
So this is my final slide. We need to do better, utilize all clinical
touchpoints to address tobacco use.
I would really encourage everybody in this conference to go beyond yes/no,
please. Don't just ask, "Are you a smoker or not?" Try to get some
information on how much they are smoking, how long they've been smoking,
because all that can be used in interventions.
Address disparities and finally, encourage people to quit all
tobacco products. And if they want to use e-cigarettes, support them,
but want them not to overuse, quit completely, and plan to quit
e-cigarettes as well. So I know I've exceeded my time, but I'm going to
stop now.
Thank you very much. We will hold Q&A
for after all the speakers have spoken.
You might want to make some notes. It's hard to keep everything in mind for
30 minutes.
Doug Wood is Chairman of the Department of Surgery at the University of Washington
and a senior surgeon and leader at the Fred Hutch Cancer Research
Center. Doug is going to talk about lung cancer screening.
Thank you, Dr. Ohman, and it's great to be part of this panel.
And, I have no disclosures,
unfortunately.
But I would start with acknowledging
something that we have to celebrate, and Dr. Ohman discussed this.
But
over the past 30 years, we've decreased cancer mortality
in the United States by 31%. And if one models
that to cancer deaths averted, that's approximately
3.2 million cancer deaths averted.
So we have a long ways to go, but we also ought to celebrate our successes.
And,
Dr. Ohman also talked about this, and I want to emphasize, this panel
represents the majority of that improvement, the biggest aspect
being cancer prevention, but the second biggest
being early detection.
And I'm obviously interested in lung cancer,
and I think the people in this audience are familiar that lung
cancer is by far the most common cause of cancer death.
In fact, it's about the same as the next four
cancer deaths combined. And in fact, if
you look at that gold bar that is the sixth most common cause
of cancer death, I think you'd be surprised to know that that
is lung cancer in never smokers.
The sixth most common cause of cancer death is lung cancer in never
smokers. And so we're here talking about
prevention and screening. I'm concentrating on screening,
and if we look 16 years ago, we had screening
for many of the major cancers, but not for lung cancer.
There was no screening for lung cancer in 2010.
And this audience is also familiar with the National Lung Screening Trial
that came out in 2010,
thatDemonstrated a 20% mortality
reduction from low-dose CT in those that were high risk for
lung cancer.
And quickly following that were guidelines.
This was the first guidelines produced about lung cancer screening
for the National Comprehensive Cancer Network, or NCCN, that
made recommendations for who should be screened after the publication
of the NLST.
And this led to a,
what there's not time to discuss, but a pretty complicated and prolonged
policy process that took about five years to
actually have implementation of coverage for lung cancer
screening in private insurance because of recommendations
from USPSTF, and
publicly insured with Medicare beneficiaries, both
occurring at the beginning of 2015, just 11
years ago.
So that's a great advance. The largest cause of cancer death
now has a screening modality, but unfortunately,
that only captures about a quarter of the individuals that are going
to die of lung cancer. So a great step forward, but missing
about 75% of the opportunity
for early cancer detection in lung cancer patients.
So fortunately, we've had additional data and additional opportunity
to expand the screening recommendations.
NCCN did two things. It both simplified
and extended the screening recommendations.
Both are important.
The improvement of the inclusion criteria,
but also the simplification to make it easier for
application of primary care providers.
And this actually was also followed, and this time in a
shorter fashion, by USPSTF in
2021, changing their recommendations to be
somewhat similar, not completely to the NCCN, they're
still more complicated, and Medicare followed a year later
in 2022. So those changes in
2015 were then further improved upon in
2021 and 2022.
This shows the impact of the implementation of lung cancer
screening, and you can see an inflection point when we started having
coverage for screening with more individuals being
identified with early-stage cancers and a
corresponding fewer number of individuals being
identified with late-stage lung cancer, exactly what we are
trying to accomplish with cancer early detection.
And remarkably, that inflection is
with only 19% of individuals being
screened.
This paper from the American Cancer Society just a few months ago
modeled that that 19% still results in a
significant number of lives saved, about 15,000 lives
saved over a five-year period.
But imagine what we could do if we had a
better inclusion of those individuals.
We could quadruple that and have over 60,000 lives
saved in five years. And if we expanded the
smoking definition, that would be another
26,000, so an approximate 90,000 lives that
could be saved if we improve the inclusion criteria and
access for lung cancer screening.
And this paper recommended revisiting the current eligibility
requirements as a result.
There are many reasons why the lung cancer screening
rate is still low, from the fact of it's
still early in the adoption, but also stigma and
nihilism have been factors that have limited access to lung
cancer care. But I'm going to concentrate on this aspect
of complicated and restrictive inclusion criteria,
and I don't have time of course to go through all the data around these, but
there's three. One is to change the
recommendation that limits lung cancer screening for those that
have stopped smoking for more than 15 years,
to eliminate the upper age limit of 80 that
exists in our policy but does not exist in the
NCCN guidelines, and maybe most
importantly, simplify the smoking metric.
We're all used to talking about pack years, but if we use smoking
duration rather than pack years, it's easier to
identify, and it turns out that it more accurately
picks up the individuals that are at risk for lung cancer and more
equitably in terms of minority individuals.
And if we weigh the balances of we don't want to screen
low-risk individuals, there's harms of that, and we want to
screen high-risk individuals, and I'm trying to emphasize that if
we're only screening 19% of high-risk individuals,
that is our priority. That is where we have to pay our attention
now, and this is the reason. The curve on the
left is a normal lung cancer survival curve of five
years, 22%. The curve on the right is a
lung cancer survival curve from the International Early Lung Cancer
Action project, 84% because of lung cancer screening.
There's few interventions that we have that result in a true
inversion of a survival curve.
And I'll come back to how I started and make this point that
we have had successes in prevention and early
detection with decreasing mortality rates in the
United States, and over the past 10 years, those
decreasing mortality rates have been largely driven by
decreasing mortality in lung cancer.And the
goal is to try to take more lung cancer victims
and help them become lung cancer survivors.
Thank you.
Well, that's a very compelling take-home message.
There's so much more that could be gained by following your
analysis and advice.
Our next speaker is Dr. Tim Rebbeck.
He is professor of Cancer Prevention and Epidemiology
at the Harvard T.H. Chan School of Public Health,
and his focus is on precision oncology, that's a
precision prevention and personalized medicine.
Thank you.
Well, thank you very much, everybody.
And I'd like to pick up on the comments that Dr.
Wood just made, that what we're trying to do is
maximize the benefits and minimize the harms of
prevention. And when I talk about prevention here, I'm going to use that generic
term, but I mean prevention, primary prevention, early detection, et
cetera, as I think all of those things fit in here.
I have no disclosures. So what is this precision
prevention concept? So it adapts the principles of precision
medicine to prevent cancer or detect it
early. It moves from this one-size-fits-all model, which you've
just heard about, for the most part, everybody should stop smoking.
Everybody should limit their exposure to these carcinogens,
to finding the right intervention for the right person at the right time.
And we believe that the increased net benefit for those at
highest risk through more intensive or earlier interventions will
maximize the benefit,
as long as we're able to reduce the harms, and
minimize the resource usage for lower risk
individuals. So it's really tailoring the strategies, so that one
size does not fit all. And what we hope to be able to do is
provide a framework that integrates novel tools, and that can
be risk stratification, adaptive risk,
biomarkers, imaging, novel liquid biopsy, multi-cancer
early detection tests in order to achieve this.
Some of these things will not be appropriate for everyone in the population, but
if we can find those people who are going to benefit from some of these novel,
perhaps more expensive, but more beneficial and less harmful tools,
that's our goal.
So the features of this kind of precision prevention,
we need risk prediction and stratification.
We have to figure out who these people are, who are at elevated
risk. And to do that, we need large
epidemiological studies that provide us information that
accurately define who's going to have
a cancer, but particularly a lethal cancer, a cancer that needs
intervention. Ideally, we'd like to have a good mechanistic foundation.
And I think Dr. Ullman's comment about the carrot in ATBC studies is a
great example, that if we'd had better, not only, but if we'd had better
mechanistic foundation, maybe we would've avoided some of the harms that would've
come. We'd love to hear more about the concept of that.
But we think that in a precision prevention approach,
we should be able to use mechanistic and biological knowledge
about carcinogenesis and who's at risk in order to develop the
interventions that are going to be most likely to work and cause the least
harm. We know that individuals have response
heterogeneity. We can think about this as pharmacogenetics, but it goes well
beyond that, that interventions are going to have different efficacies and
toxicities in different groups. And we need to think about what those risk-benefit
ratios are going to be. We don't want to just increase
the intervention, the intensity of the intervention.
We also want to tailor those to match the preventive
strategy to individual risk tiers and again,
minimize harm. We need to have optimized timing
to intervene at the right point in the carcinogenesis process, and this
might require updating. This was going to require new data, but it also might
require the individual's risk information to be updated
over time. So this is where a risk adaptive approach really
is important.
So what you can see in this figure is that there's a
continuum. So precision prevention, first of all,
complements guideline-based strategies.
So, colonoscopy, Pap smears, a low-dose
CT screening for lung cancer are not to be taken
away. But the risk adaptive and precision
prevention approach will then tailor on top of those to understand the
timing, the dose, the intervention intensity,
and maybe add new interventions on top of the guideline-based
strategies.
So it's difficult to do this, as you can imagine.
It sounds good to say, well, we're going to find the right people.
We're going to spend our energy intervening in them.
We're going to reduce the intensity of the intervention on others.
But this means a few things. It means there's added complexity for
patients and clinicians. So
there's extra steps, there's risk assessment, there's communication, there's
understanding
why you're doing this more intensive screening, and
that isn't easy in a healthcare setting,
particularly in a primary care health setting where
people are very busy and may not be paying attention to these things or have the
bandwidth to do so. There are a lot of evidence gaps, so we would love to
say there are risk models for all the cancers that we care about that guide
interventions. That's not the case.
Clearly, the more intense interventions that we might be
talking about may happen or may afford
better care to some populations better than others, those that
have better access, those that have more specialized
opportunities for care. And so we're really concerned that by doing this,
equity issues will arise and that disparities can result.
And obviously, people need to understand,
they need to trust what's going on here.
And in particular, we don't want to just increase screening for everybody or
prevention for everybody. There are going to be some people that are at lower risk,
and we're going to have to be able to say to them, "We're not giving you as much
attention, and we're not giving you as much intervention as the next
person."Can people be trusted or can people trust that
message from healthcare?
What is required to make this work?
Robust models, user-friendly tools, implementation
science that
gives evidence-based
guidance to how health systems can be redesigned to
accommodate these potentially very complex
pathways to precision care,
and policy reimbursement regulation of these
tools need to be there. And again, as I suggested,
equity-focused design. We can't wait until these fancier tools, these
molecular stratification tools, create
disparities. They will, unless we design the tools and the strategies
around an equity lens.
So our success will depend on a
conceptual shift from who stands to benefit the most and how do we reduce
harm in those individuals. And for those of you who have been following the early
detection story, there's a lot of voices out there that are very
anti-early detection because they see that the
harms outweigh the benefits. And in some cases, that's true.
But by incorporating risk adaptive strategies and
precision methods, we may be able to reduce that harm, maximize that benefit,
and then get around some of these arguments that are out there in the field that
make early detection less palatable to some
scientists, some clinicians, and some patients.
And there needs to be a strong evidence base for how we implement
these and the willingness to act with imperfect evidence.
Because most of these tools are not going to be based around very large
100,000-person, 20-year follow-up studies.
The gold standard of evidence may have to be
modified in order to make these tools
accessible and available and policy-friendly.
But we're not necessarily going to have the gold standard of evidence that we've
come to expect. And clinicians and health systems have to
integrate
this new way of thinking, because it is going to be more work. It is more complex.
It might be more expensive. Hopefully, if it's done right, it will be
implemented in a way that it saves lives, causes less harm.
So I just thank my colleagues who have been working on this and thinking about this
with me. Thank you very much.
Thank you, Tim.
Our next speaker is
Dr. Electra Paskett.
She's a member of the AACR Board of Directors, and she's
director of the Division of Cancer Prevention and Control at
the Ohio State University.
Thank you, Dr. Ohman, and hello everybody, and thank you for being here this
afternoon. And
we have heard some great talks, and I hope that this adds to it in
the continuum of this prevention and screening.
So these are my disclosures. So this is what I'm going to briefly touch on,
are screening tests, new tests and availability, the screening process.
If there's one thing you get from my talk, I hope it's this, and policy
implications. So let's just remember for a minute the purpose of the
screening test. It is to detect cancers at early stages where they are more
easily treated. We avoid late stage, and we
do this with lower cost, lower loss of
productivity, and we reduce deaths.
The test must be found to be efficacious, meaning that it
reduces death and/or late-stage disease.
The test must be acceptable. Tim alluded a little bit
to that. And it must be cost-effective.
And there must be a treatment available if it is
diagnosed at early stage.
So these are our recommended screening tests, whatever guidelines you
want to use. And Dr. Wood did a great presentation on lung cancer
screening,
and I do have the stars there for shared decision-making documentation
required for reimbursement.
And Dr. Wood also talked a little bit about the uptake.
Well, in the US and other high-income countries, you can see the uptake is pretty
high. Okay, I'll go to 18% for lung.
And then for low-income countries, however, the rates range from 40% for
breast, 1% for colorectal, and 15% for cervical
cancer, and I don't have estimates for lung screening.
There's a huge problem in these low-income countries for low
access to the tests and/or their treatment.
In some countries, why do we screen?
Because we don't even have the treatment, right?
That is very common in some countries, and we need to keep that in mind.
So let's move to new tests. Are the new tests really
good? They're shiny new toys. But what about
access for everybody? Okay, so Guardant Shield, and that was one of my
disclosures,
that we did do some work on acceptability of the blood test.
Is insurance covering it? It is FDA approved.
Is insurance covering it? Is there ability to access tests?
For example, does your healthcare system have the right
forms to order the test yet? And worldwide
access, is this accessible worldwide?
The answer is no, unfortunately not yet.
My dear friends in Malaysia, they can't get it because there's not a processing
plant close. Something we need to work on.
Cervical cancer self-testing. Yay, FDA approval.
Thank you, Phil and your division.
For in the clinic and at home. It benefits women who can't attend the clinic or
have barriers to exams.
But how is it being implemented in the health systems? Do they have the forms?
Do they have the tests? Is insurance paying for it? Do they have the routine?
No. All right? So there's a lot here with implementation.
And then my really important point is that it's not just a screening test, it's a
screening process. The test is not complete until a positive
test is resolved.Which means the patient
returns to normal follow-up schedule, meaning the abnormality's been resolved,
or they start treatment for cancer.
Very, very few health centers have any system to track test
results and follow up. They don't even know who got one, what were their
results, did they get follow-up? Current follow-up rates,
timely and appropriate. Okay, timely and appropriate
follow-up in the US, mammography, 66%, cervical screening,
60%. I did my doctoral dissertation in the late
1980s at University of Washington, when Gil was their
dean, and it was 60%. It's still 60%
today. Lung screening. From two papers I got, the range is
between 48% and 58%, and for FIT, FOBT
18% to 57%. And those rates
range from federally qualified health centers, et cetera.
And all of these rates are lower among underserved populations.
The reasons, you might ask, are multilevel, the health system, and the provider,
and the patient. My first breast cancer, they didn't tell me I had an
abnormal until my OBGYN called and said, "What about that test?"
I said, "What test?" And he said, "Oops."
So,
where is the role of policy in screening uptake?
First of all, access to tests. Can we expand the availability of
testing and especially follow-up?
What about private and public partnerships in low and middle income
countries to get the tests there and the treatment?
Coverage of services. I'm going to talk in a minute about Medicaid expansion.
The Breast and Cervical Cancer Detection Program, they run out of money.
They only cover about 18% of eligible women who could get services.
Not every state has colon cancer screening in the early detection program.
Co-pays are killing us, especially for the follow-up tests.
At Ohio State, my staff have an abnormal mammogram.
The out-of-pocket copay is $800 to
$1,600, right? That's why we need to
have screening process, not test.
Clinician health system responsibility, both for the invitation for screening and
for the follow-up. We need systems. We need to utilize patient navigators.
Clinicians and health systems need to be updated
on new guidelines and follow-up recommendations.
We design new tests, and we change the guidelines all the time,
but nobody's telling the individual primary care providers how to
incorporate that in the 10 minutes that they have for their patient who comes in
with chronic disease. And that includes also updates on the newer
technology, which I've alluded to with some of the tests.
So here's a great example, the impact of Medicaid
expansion. In states that expanded Medicaid, and this is a great
paper by Scharfer et al. that came out in "Cancer Discovery" at the
end of last year based on American Cancer Society data, et cetera.
But
if you expand Medicaid, you give greater access to healthcare,
which contributes to increased use of screening, which contributes to late-stage
disease. And what was published in this new paper is
improvements in cancer survival, especially among rural,
high poverty areas and cancers with usually worse diagnosis.
Here is a natural experiment and
data evidence that it works. Final thoughts.
Screening tests can reduce cancer mortality, but the rates are suboptimal
and vary by test and country. New tests might offer promise, but
there are issues with implementations.
Follow-up of positive screens is problematic.
Policy solutions, expansion of Medicaid to all states.
Add colon cancer coverage for all states through the Breast and Cervical Cancer
Early Detection Program. Look at the insurance coverage for new tests.
When the FDA approves, insurance should cover it right away.
Change the wording of what screening is.
Change screening tests to screening process so we can get the follow-up
covered. And link reimbursement to quality services,
which includes patient navigation and follow-up.
And if we have time, I can give you an example of a success story where
policy actually worked. So thank you all very much for your attention.
So before I call on Phil Castle, let me just mention that
in the slides that I showed in the beginning,
we had the
details, figures from a paper from Dr.
Goddard and his group and several other members, quite a few other members of
the Division of Cancer Prevention, which he directs at the
National Cancer Institute in Bethesda.
And
getting the data and putting it in front of us should generate
policy interest
in the right times, policy action,
and I think we ought to hear it directly from him now.
The theme that the best cancer is the cancer that never happens.
Thank you. Phil?
It's good to see everybody.
It's a tough group to follow. I'll see what I can do here.
So I represent the other population science division at the NCI.
We are the ones that brought you NLST and TMIST and the SHIP
trial.
So, we're very proud of the work that my staff does to support
the innovation. So to put this in perspective,
the number of people who are sitting in this room is about
40%. So those are the cancers that we can prevent right now.
Our division is interested in the empty seats, the 60% that we
don't have a strategy for now, and I'm going to talk a little bit about that.
So these are my disclaimers, just my opinions. Whoops.
So how do we reduce the burden of cancer?
How do we reduce cancer mortality?
And it really is a continuum of care that we have to consider, and it's not
just one of these, it's all these working in hand.
So we have to prevent the cancers we can prevent, control the cancers we can't
prevent, treat the cancers we can't controlAnd take care of the
cancer survivors who are now 6% of the total population in the United
States and are at at least twofold greater risk of new
cancers. And we've referred to this paper, I won't cover it,
but we really wanted to highlight the importance of prevention and control
going forward. So this is the audience participation part, and you have to
participate, or I do not go forward in this talk.
I promise you. I have threatened many cancer centers.
So
you have a choice. Would you rather have your cancer prevented or treated?
For those in favor of prevention, please raise your hand.
Those that would rather have their cancer treated, please raise your hand.
Okay. That's quite some. All right.
Now, I'm going to add another question to this.
How many people in this room
either do foundational research that supports cancer prevention
or actually does cancer prevention research or advocacy for cancer prevention?
Okay. So most of you do prevention work, which is part of our
problem. We're not bringing enough people.
These seats should be full of people.
We need to pull people in, the translational
researchers, and get them interested in this problem, which obviously
impacts not only mortality but
when we start thinking about metrics like years of life gained and
quality-adjusted years of life gained, the impact is just so much greater than
we could ever achieve in treatment, but that never gets talked about.
We use cancer mortality as our endpoint because it's easy, but it
undersells the value of prevention and control, and we have to change the narrative
if we want to change the outcomes. So this is just laying
out that at the
sort of underlying pinnings of all this is really understanding natural history,
where we can't stop investing in the basic science of
carcinogenesis.
And by doing so, we will generate opportunities to
do prophylaxis, in other words, prevent initiation, interception,
in which we come in and we find something abnormal, and we stop it and we've had
several people talk about this, and mitigation, which is finding cancer
early enough that we actually can avert death.
So I'm just going to highlight in a very high level what we support at the
NCI, and it's really this early translational work from
T0,
which is discovery and foundational research related to
development of new
interventions for cancer prevention, all the way almost into
effectiveness. But at that point, we really sort of hand off to the other
extramural population division called Division of Cancer Control and Population
Sciences. We support three areas: preventive agent development,
biomarkers for screening and early detection, and symptom
science prevention and management.
And we won't get to the last one, but it's a very critical one that we do
not enough work on.
This is just to highlight. There's going to be a lot of acronyms.
You can have these slides. You can go to the website and do this.
I want to illustrate, though, that there's this R&D pipeline that we support.
On the left side here are programs like CAPiT, which is an agent
and target discovery program. We have a natural products program.
We have a cancer immunoprevention program.
And these go into a
contract mechanism called PREVENT, which really bridges the
valley of death from discovery into clinical trials.
And so it's a stepwise approach to evaluating
promising new agents. And of course, the follow-up is great because the bar is very
high for prevention and control. If you are successful, and I don't know what
happened to the slide, but we have an early-phase clinical trial program called
CPCTnet and then NCOR, which is our national program for
large clinical trials. We also have this, again, a very
busy slide. Don't get caught up in the acronyms.
I just want to give you a sense that we have a lot of programs on discovery and
foundational research. EDRN
is sort of the translational
consortium. And then we have programs like NCOR and CSRN, which
is the new Cancer Screening Research Network.
And programs like EDRN are focused on finding biomarkers, like for lung
cancer, for lower-risk
individuals so that we can actually increase the impact of lung cancer
screening by finding people at risk that may not be heavy smokers.
I want to highlight this paper, and we don't have enough time to go through all
this, but the challenges of prevention are real.
And partly because it's a statistical argument, I can't point to any
individual and say, "I've prevented your cancer."
I can say, "I've reduced the risk by 10%." That's hard to translate
into individuals and what it means to an individual.
Success is individual. Keeping healthy people healthy, which should be celebrated,
it's hard to see. So we have to think also about new strategies,
and I think one of them is we should pay for prevention, as somebody mentioned.
We should make it cheaper. We should get employers involved.
We should even consider how we do prevention as a whole
wellness visit, not, "You're going to get your mammography today, and tomorrow,
you're going to get something else." And that idea that we would come for each
tissue or organ or just for cancer has to go away.
We have to think about the gestalt of the person and take care of the whole person.
What are some of the barriers? Well, one of them, and we're actually going to have
a meeting about this I hope later this year or early next
year, are what are some of the policy-related issues?
Patents last for 17 years. It takes probably 17 years to develop
the evidence that there's a
new preventive strategy, which means that no company's going to invest in that
because they're going to lose their patent.
So we need to come up with different ways to reward those that invest in this.
It's a high bar for benefits to harms. Tim talked about this a lot.
I won't do that. But we have a low tolerance for risk because we're going into
healthy populations.
And then we need new economic models for prevention and control because it takes so
long to see the population benefit, right?
It takes 10,
15 years to see the impact of HPV vaccination at a population level.
So-Companies and governments, they
wanna see their return on investment now, and we have to think of different ways to
incentivize all of them to jump into this space.
I know I'm out of time. This is my last slide.
If we want better prevention and control, we have to emphasize it.
We have to commit to it. And to the point, we only
have 40% in this room, right? So there's the
problem. There's the symptom right here.
We have to increase funding, and believe me, I advocate for this all the time.
I'm not sure anybody's listening, but we actually have to put money where our
mouth is if we want better. It can't just be a verbal commitment.
It actually has to be dollars on the table.
By putting that money in, we bring in more mentors who then train the
next generation. We get more trainees.
We get an increased workforce, more PIs, more research, more
innovation,
because this is not easy. And then we increase public awareness,
and we provide strategies for people to stay healthy.
And there's no greater calling
than keeping healthy people healthy.
And with that, I will say thank you very much. A couple cartoons to entertain you.
Thanks.
That was terrific. All of the talks were terrific. Thank you very much.
We covered the waterfront,
but I think we've basically scratched the surface on what might be interest from
some of you. We have a few questions to follow up immediately
with the panelists, and then we'll turn it over to the audience.
HPV vaccination was mentioned, cervical cancers.
I plead with all of you to talk about cancers in the plural.
When you use the word cancer as a noun, we should respect the fact that one of the
biggest advances under the war
on cancer from 55 years ago has been the
recognition that cancers are extremely
heterogeneous by different sites of origin,
by different patients, different samples of the
same tumor in the same patient,
and different sampling in the patient over time, including
metastases. And if we can't transmit that message,
we're going to be behind the learning curve on everything that follows.
So let me ask about
keeping pace with rapidly evolving nicotine products.
I think you presented it
beautifully.
What would you like to emphasize where we can make the biggest difference?
Is this on?
Yes, it is.
Okay.
I think one of the biggest things we can probably do is get
access to interventions,
do a better job of getting access to interventions, but more importantly, also
follow the policy. So, there were two policies that were actually
under consideration, which as a tobacco-- most of the people in the tobacco
community really felt would have had an impact, which is removing menthol
in cigarettes. Menthol cigarettes are one of the most popular
cigarettes, and they really maintain the appeal of smoking for cigarettes.
Removing menthol in cigarettes and the second policy that was under
consideration was reducing the amount of nicotine that is available in
cigarettes. Now, either of these policies could have had a huge impact, but
unfortunately, they were not followed upon.
And I think really thinking about issues like
that will have a bigger population impact on reducing smoking.
Anybody else want to comment?
We're highly specialized.
Well, I will say
that
in the previous government administration, there was, at the
FDA, a discussion about lowering nicotine below addictive levels-
Mm-hmm
... which has been lost, I'm sure.
Yes.
That would be a big impact on all of this.
I do worry about e-cigarettes and other nicotine products in terms
of being a gateway drug. The answer is to, I still think, to go at this
straight up and
we talk about changing policy. We've talked about changing policy
in sugar in beverages.
Yeah.
And that's been around for 20 years, and we haven't done it, okay?
So it's time to belly up to the bar and
put policies in place that make it harder to become addicted to
cigarettes and to maintain that addiction.
Yeah, even in this meeting several years ago, I recall that the
audiences for whether
e-cigarettes would be a way to reduce smoking of
cigarettes prevalence
drew a lot more people
than what to do about hooking young adolescents
on nicotine.
Yeah. If I can just add one more point.
I think to follow up on what Phil just said, I think
having the processes and having the dollars and following through on our
commitments is important because one example of this is,
we should not get complacent and assume, "Hey, we've solved that problem.
We've solved smoking problems." And the removal, for
example, of the CDC Office of Smoking and Health last year was
enormously harmful to all the
processes and procedures we have established to make sure
that people get smoking cessation intervention.
So getting
access to people and having the dollars there is really important, too.
Great.
With regard to HPV vaccination,
do we recommend it for a broad enough age range of
women and men?
Okay, I'll take that one since I do research in that.
So, really,
it's recommended from age nine to 45,
and after
26, it's a shared decision-making
discussion.But I don't think we use that
enough, and people can argue with me about the efficacy of
the vaccine over age 26. But
the Appalachian area that I work in, the
women
have higher prevalence of HPV
than the rest of the United States, and being able to get the
vaccine up to age 45 would be tremendous.
And it also is a role model for their children who are
trying to get vaccinated.
It's also the age range recommended and implemented in Australia.
Up to 45? Yeah.
So I'm going to
respectfully-
I knew you would
... disagree.
I knew you would. And that's fine. That's fine.
And-
I'm out on the front line, but that's fine.
And in fact, the fact that you see a high prevalence means the ship has left the
dock. Okay? That they've already gotten the infection.
If you look at the six countries that have reported out at national
level impact on cervical cancer, it was only the
group 17 and younger that saw any
significant reductions in cervical cancer incidents.
The most cost-effective thing we can do is make sure that
every
person under the age of 17, or 17 and under, or 18, somewhere
around there, gets their dose. And the fact is, this has taken
us almost 20 years to get to the levels
of coverage that Australia achieved in the first year.
In the first year. In
2007, they had
80% coverage with three doses, and we haven't gotten there
with one dose yet.
That is the problem.
Well, the most controversial part of the problem in this country, I think, has
been the starting age rather than the highest.
So,
the way it was rolled out in the United States, and I know some of my
friends are here in implementation science and do this, it was
not rolled out correctly.
Agree.
They never came to us to ask us how to implement
this as a cancer vaccine. It was
linked immediately with sexual promiscuity in this country,
which killed it from the beginning.
And my dear colleague here, you are right.
If we could get the children and the adolescents
under 18 vaccinated, I would agree with you a million percent, but we're not.
And it is a little more acceptable to get older women and
men vaccinated. And
the HPV vaccine is nine valent. Covers
nine strains.
If you're infected not with all nine, you're infected with one
that is not a 16 or an 18, you could still get the
vaccine, and it will be preventive option for you.
If we can't get the kids vaccinated, what are we going to do?
Say no to the older women who want it, who might be changing sexual partners, going
into a new relationship? I just don't think we're looking
at what Tim was talking about,
which is who needs it and who will get it, et cetera.
So we can debate for a long time, Phil, but I'm out in the
trenches and I see these women, and
we need to really change how we think about it.
All right. I'm out in the trenches, too.
So even though I sit at the NCI, I am also an active
researcher.
So my answer to you is we need to do the trial
that
shows that HPV vaccine can be delivered as part of the early
pediatric series.
And it becomes integrated, and it becomes part of the alphabet soup
rather than this preteen, just before you're going to have
sex,
we're going to give you the vaccine.
If it becomes part of your DTPV, MR or
MMR in this country and so forth.
But that's how we're doing it.
Well, see, that's the way, it all depends how you describe it.
If it's just before you're going to have sex.
But if it's something that you probably certainly should have had
earlier-
It was an anti-cancer vaccine
... and you never did,
maybe they shouldn't be neglected thereafter.
But
most of us who do the implementation and test implementation
science in the clinics, that's what we do,
is we say you couple it with the other childhood
vaccines. That's the standard that we employ.
And I see my friends shaking their heads yes, that that's how
we do it, Phil, and it's not working.
No, I'm talking about giving it to one and two-year-olds.
I'm not talking about nine.
Oh.
I'm talking about-
The one and two-year-olds?
I'm talking about developing the evidence so that it becomes part of your
infectious disease-
Yeah, okay
...
program.
This could be a whole session.
Yeah.
Sounds like it's going to be.
Yeah. So let's move on.
It is one of our biggest successes, so getting it implemented right
to have a maximal benefit is high priority, I would say.
I would just add, I do a lot of work in Rwanda.
And Rwanda has a 93%
vaccination success rate among the lower than 18.
So to me, it's a policy question.
At what age do they start?
Same, nine to 17. Something-
In, I think, middle school.
Yeah, they do it in schools, but they-
There's no catch-up.
It's just done.
Sixth grade.
Yes, exactly. So the issue is, it's a policy question.
In Rwanda, they've said every child, every girl at least, mostly because they
don't do all boys necessarily,
in the sixth grade, they get their vaccination and there's no questions.
And I don't know that we could do that here because we can't just force
people to have the vaccination. But a
well-designed policy with good education, as they've done in Rwanda,
gets near complete coverage, and so we could do
that. In Rhode Island, where they have the highest rate of HPV vaccination in
the country, that's because they do it in schools.
And so there are ways of doing this.
There's a lot of questions, as you can see, but policy is the thing that
makes all the difference.That's correct.
Okay.
Now let's take a little turn on chemo prevention
agent development.
Among all the things that fall in the categories you showed on the slide,
what would you say, Phil, is the most promising set of chemical
approaches
or drug development approaches for chemo prevention of cancer?
So I want to retire the term chemo prevention because it's not used
consistently and it invokes the idea of chemo.
So I think it should go away. That's just my personal opinion.
All right.
And I've written about it,
with Tim actually.
So I'm going to take a step back. I think
that where we should double down, like if somebody said, "You have to spend
$1,000 of your personal money, where would you spend it?" I would say I
would spend it on understanding the host immune response.
And the reason for that is that I believe that we are constantly challenged with
mutations in early lesions, pre-cancers,
and our body handles them and handles them over and over and over until we get
older, and we undergo immune senescence.
So if I were going to really double down and say, "I'm willing to spend
20 years working on this,"
I would invest in understanding what a normal,
healthy immune response is, what is a healthy immune system,
and then build off of there. Because the other problem is going from tissue
to tissue to try to prevent cancer is slow and
ineffective in many, many ways. Whereas if we could harness
the immune system to increase surveillance for many tumor sites,
that's the Holy Grail.
Well, we're living in an era of maximal interest and investment-
Right. That's exactly correct
... in all kinds of immune modification therapies.
And we-
Why can't we make this kind of investment?
Well, we have proposed something, but things have not been, let's say,
normal at the NIH right now, okay?
Doug, you want to weigh in on this?
Do you want to weigh in on this?
No, Doug.
Doug.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, I don't really have any experience in the... Sorry.
I don't have any experience in the-
It's all about strategy. This isn't about the specific chemicals.
It's about whether it's
immunoprevention.
Yeah. And I'm much more on the treatment side,
so you're right that
in lung cancer, well, with all of our cancers, but lung leading,
the immunotherapies are
making a huge difference.
And whether or not we can roll that back
as a preventive agent, I guess,
I count on experts like Phil to
come up with ways for us to do that.
Well, I want to be clear. Although some people are now working on
taking immunotherapy agents into the advanced
pre-cancer
state, and that's fine. They're probably using lower doses.
I'm saying take a step back further and saying, "Invest in
what we know works most of the time and figure out how to harness it."
Because if I can prevent
a whole bunch of cancers by enhancing the immune system, okay...
And it's not just we're going to turn on the immune system, because of course you
would just cause autoimmunity. You have to actually understand what's going on-
Yeah, of course
... and do it in a precision medicine approach, if you will, to
build off Tim's talk. But that's
where I think we have new technologies for delivering antigens.
The mRNA vaccines, and
they're now next generation and probably subsequent generations, not
only that we can scale up them quickly and we can actually pick out
neoantigens and plug them into the cassette, but there are going to
be enhancements of that in terms of adjuvant
activity and so forth. So I think understanding the
immune system, understanding what are the new antigens we can leverage, and
then having these innovative platforms to do it.
And it's not just innovation in terms of delivery, just the discovery part.
Every time you go into the lab and you say, "I want to test this
antigen," okay? Before you'd have to send it off and have it
synthesized, or you'd have to do recombinant
production of that antigen. The fact that you can very quickly put
a sequence into an mRNA cassette and test it in the animal model
and figure out what are the best antigens to go forward and how to present them
is a huge step forward in cancer research and in cancer prevention research.
So have you already published this recommendation?
No.
Maybe we should get this on the agenda for next year at this meeting.
Sure.
And figure out how to proceed and
plant a seed that's going to grow.
If I could just riff on-
Please
... what Phil just said.
One of the things that I don't think we take as much advantage of as we could is
this concept of reverse translation of agents
that are used in therapy earlier into the
carcinogenesis process. So Juan Kihong at MD Anderson had
some really great thoughts about this that we should be looking back at.
Tamoxifen is a great example. It started as a
therapeutic agent. It can be used for chemoprevention.
Isn't used much, but should be. There's some really great examples in
myeloma right now where chemotherapeutic agents
used to treat
multiple myeloma are now being used in smoldering myeloma before people
develop the end organ damage and things like that.
Just a session on that two hours ago.
Oh, right. Missed that. Sorry, yeah.
But I think we have a lot of agents. We have a lot of
things that we use to treat cancer.
Many of them are very toxic, of course.
But if you think about precision medicine again, and you're at extremely high risk
of developing a cancer that's likely to kill you,
you may be able, willing to have the risk, have the
toxicities of these agents and/or modify them to
be less toxic by dosing
or something like thatBut we don't talk a lot about that, and
I'd love to hear what Phil thinks about it.
Well, and I think the tamoxifen story is a great example of this.
So right, we started with treatment.
Yep.
Then we showed, like the IBIS trials and so forth, showed that tamoxifen
reduced risk, but the
side effects were too great and so we've had very poor...
Now the division of cancer prevention has been supporting what we call baby
tox.
Mm-hmm. Yep.
Just low dose to... Baby tam.
Baby tam. Yeah.
Thank you. Baby tam, and that looks like it's working.
So this is another way of precision prevention.
So we often focus precision prevention in our idea of like, we're going to
understand the biological mechanisms and then we're going to
target those, and that is precision prevention, but another way
to think about precision prevention is tailoring or
adapting, whether it's a self collection.
That isn't traditionally thought as precision, but yes, we're meeting the needs of
the population by coming up with a way that they're willing to undergo cervical
cancer screening
or low dose TAM or, thinking about
strategies, yeah, and to me this is the undiscovered country,
like topical delivery. So you're delivering to
the organ at risk, or you're delivering it so that you don't
get... Maybe it's a broad acting agent, but you're not having to deal
with it systemically in a way that enhances or has
higher
side effects. These are all different kinds of precision, but we...
And even precision prevention from, and Tim alluded to this,
coming up with strategies to reduce the harms.
So the benefits might be the same, but if we thought about strategies to reducing
harms, which again is like topical or lower dose,
that is another form of precision prevention.
Right. And lower doses might be particularly effective
in pre-malignant-
Exactly.
Absolutely.
... pathology.
Mm-hmm.
And molecular monitoring to see as people's pre-malignant lesions look like
they're starting to advance. Myeloma is the classic example of this.
You molecularly monitor for somatic changes over time, and once
you see a few triggers that look like you're really starting to advance, you
start upping the agents that you give people, is
people will be more willing to accept toxicities if they see the
risk-
Purpose
... and they understand the harms and the benefits that they might
receive. And that's precision again.
That's the idea. Please come to the microphones and ask questions.
Who would like to start?
All right.
Hi. Really great panel.
I wanted to pick up on something Phil mentioned, but I think
is relevant to all the panelists, which is this
idea of making the case. I think with policymakers, it usually comes
down to dollars and cents, who's going to pay for it.
Who's going to cover it? And I wonder,
I think a lot of us really are feely touchy
and want to save the world, but there's practical issues when you're in
government.
I'm not an economist,
but I would love to do more work, and how can we encourage that kind of work to
make sure that we are making the case better to policymakers?
Who would like to pick that up?
Well, I'll just say that we have CISNET, which has been an incredible national
resource. It's an ongoing consortium.
It's been around for 20 something years, and those are the
people that are doing the health economic analyses.
Now,
I think what we really need to do is, particularly when we're talking about
exposures that impact multiple diseases, not just cancer, we need to start
developing models to say, if we reduce,
BMI, if we
reduce alcohol intake, if we reduce smoking, it doesn't just affect
cancer. None of the modeling goes that far, but
that starts to make the case even stronger.
I would also say, coming back to my previous comment, we have to stop using
mortality as the endpoint. I know it's convenient and easy, but it really
undersells the value of cancer prevention and control, which is all those
healthy years that you lived
in excess. Whereas treatment, you may be
stopping the person from dying of that cancer, but it's not great.
Believe me, I've taken care of my wife and my father, and
it's not a great quality of life. And it's not very long either.
So
part of it is rethinking about how we do these
models, going forward.
Well, we've got a mass experiment on if we're making studies of it
on BMI reduction.
So if I could-
If I can add something.
Sorry.
So I think science is great. We all do the work, and we develop all
these relationships, and we develop these tests.
But are you getting the information out?
Do we do a good enough job of informing the public, informing your
policymakers, responding to... The government puts out
policies all the time that they ask for input on.
How many people here actually read those and respond to them?
You need to respond to them if they ask for input, because this is the way that you
can influence your policymakers.
This is the way you can talk to the parent in your community, talk to the child in
your community, the teachers. These are the people who are going to make
a noise and influence policymakers and make a difference.
And can I just add one thing, that the language we use and the
way we communicate it is incredibly important. And I love AACR.
AACR is my home, but I have this thing in front of me, and it says,
"AACR, finding cures together." So cures are great.
I don't have anything against curing cancer, but why doesn't it say finding cures
and prevention together or something like that?
This is a language thing that even AACR, who values
prevention, is not talking about.
So I would just say that the language we use, the way we present this
information to everybody, to the scientific community, to the policy community,
matters. And finding cures together limits the way we
think about
what we need to be doing.
But I would reverse the order. Finding prevention-
Right
... and cures together.
So, and I'm with you.
Those are good points.
And we need to roll up our sleeves and be willing to
engage with policymakers. So when
USPSTF recommended lung cancer screening,
Medcac, for Medicare,
had a panel. I testified at that along with others, and-
CMS voted, the MEDCAC panel said
no to lung cancer screening.
So that was upsetting. But a group of us
went to senior Medicare administrators, and we worked
with them to help them understand the data.
A series of meetings, a white paper that ultimately led to
Medicare deciding to cover lung cancer screening
for Medicare beneficiaries in spite of their own panel having
recommended against it. I think that's the first time that
CMS has overturned the recommendation of a MEDCAC panel.
But it required
tenacity, I guess, I would say, of not giving up
just because there was a negative finding.
Very important point. You're next.
Hi. Thanks. Victor Chubuk from Freedom.
I wanted to go into a little bit more detail about something Dr.
Reddock mentioned in his talk.
We're big believers in the right screening test for the right person based on their
individual factors. But, we also have to acknowledge that other than smoking, which
is a huge outlier, most of the risk factors we know about are pretty modest in
terms of enrichment or in terms of how many actual cases they pick up.
So I'm wondering if you have
a quantitative cutoff in mind of what is actually a sufficiently useful factor to
dictate who gets what kind of screening and what risk factors you're most excited
about.
Yeah. Well, first of all, I think it's really important to recognize that one
size doesn't fit all also means that some things do fit
all. And, if we're talking about an MCED test, we're talking about some kind of a
liquid biopsy. Maybe that does fit all.
And so that, I just wanted to make it clear that we're not talking about things
being mutually exclusive. Because it's precision doesn't mean we have to ignore
population-wide things. So the risk factors, I think, that we need to be thinking
about are going to vary from
cancer to cancer and population to population.
And I think that we need to be very careful about defining
risk factors that are
misapplied. So, for example, obesity is an incredibly important risk factor, but
it's not important for many cancers.
So we need to be very clear if we say we're going to
stratify individuals based on their risk and then have an intervention, that we do
it in a way that's thoughtful and recognizes the heterogeneity
and the, in both in risk and in outcomes that we're seeing.
So that's hard because what it means is we have to think about
67 diseases, not one disease, and we have to have primary care
people stratify risk in a way that's thoughtful and leads to interventions that
will benefit. And so I don't, just want to make that point.
So let me... I would like to add to that.
So
other than genetic predisposition, we are not very good at risk stratification.
Right.
Okay. And that's why we need to double down
on epidemiologic, molecular epidemiologic, and
lab-based research on factors and go
back and forth and even, can we use AI to identify
pre-- Help us elucidate the natural history of
disease. The more that we can elaborate that natural history,
the better we will eventually be able to re-stratify and be able to pull people out
who are at higher risk, and to Tim's point, also identify people who
are at lower risk that we should leave alone.
That's right.
Or do it less in. Okay. And even when we,
Tim's point about multi-cancer detection. Notice I didn't say early.
Yes. Right.
I refuse to give you that.
MCED. Yeah. Mm-hmm.
Okay. Those target different cancers. So which one should you get?
Which one should I get? Which one should Electra and Tim and the rest of the panel
get? Well, that would depend on your risk factors, right?
So if you are a BRCA carrier, and you're a woman, you'd
certainly want something for ovarian, breast, and pancreatic
as an obvious example. So even something that's really meant to be a
broad screening test for multiple cancers, the companies
have developed different technologies that target different cancers, and that
should be
tied to your risk profile. Right? So there's a lot of work to do on risk.
And I think, I can't remember who mentioned it, but the other challenge is about
communication is that
risk is not well understood in the population. Okay? We learned that from COVID.
And so we have to educate the population about what risk
means and what it doesn't mean. So the-
Okay, let's go on.
Yep, sorry.
Yeah. Hi. Lori Pierce, University of Michigan. Great panel.
And my comment actually dovetails on the first question from the audience.
One of my pet peeves regarding navigation-
Speak up a little more
... Navigation and reimbursement for navigation.
We can certainly increase the number of
tests that we have for early detection. That's very important.
But we could optimize so much of what we currently have.
And in terms of low-hanging fruit, navigation's got to be really up there.
And I don't understand why we have policies that we can't change
that would facilitate and increase the use of navigation
to reach rural populations, reach our Black and brown
populations, getting the word out there, communication.
What can we do as a scientific group to promote the
importance of navigation?
So I think, Lori, that navigation is understood
by a lot of people.
Mm-hmm.
And, I was part of the original Patient Navigation Research program, which
demonstrated navigation is efficacious.
And since then, we in the American Cancer Society, ACS, CAN,
have lobbied for reimbursement.
Right.
So we did get, under the Biden administration,
the CMS reimbursement for patient navigation using PIN codes.
Mm-hmm.
I can tell you there are very few institutions in this country that are using the
PIN codes.
That's right. That's right.
The reason is
we don't want people to get a bill
for a copay. We don't think that patients should have to do
a copay for patient navigation.
Secondly, those codes are hard to
understand
We don't know if you have to have a
provider that puts their number in so that you can get
reimbursed. So because the way it was done,
the way the policy was written,
it is not well understood and easily
understood in this country by our healthcare systems.
That's why it's not being used.
I know there are some institutions that have figured out how to
eliminate the self-pay so patients don't have to pay.
Most institutions have not figured that out.
I know. I said some.
And
again, it's very few institutions that are doing this.
So we are trying, again, in ACS, ACS CAN, and
others, to work with CMS. When you were talking about when the
requests for information come out, respond.
So a bunch of us responded about the pin codes and
responded about the difficulty.
Yeah.
And I don't know where that's going.
And under this administration, do they want to do that?
But I will tell you, there are tons of institutions
that know the return on investment for navigators, and they are coughing
up for patient navigators. Not everybody, but there are a
ton that pay for patient navigation.
And we have navigators. We don't use nurse navigators
predominantly. We use oncology navigators.
There's certification for navigators now.
Patients love them,
et cetera. But the way the policy for
reimbursement was done, it was not done correctly.
Please.
Okay. Hi there. My name is Dakota Jones.
I'm a PhD student at the University of Southern California here in Los Angeles.
Me and my students sitting here, we were loving the discourse on HPV vaccination,
and that's actually my dissertation topic and what I presented my poster on today,
HPV vaccination in tribal health settings.
So very interested in FQHCs,
in cancer disparities in general. So obviously love the conversation we've had.
I have two questions though. My first would be, do you think it's a
viable use of time and resources to advocate for policy
change on HPV vaccination given the climate on
vaccines these days? It's kind of a loaded question.
That's first. And then second, any kind of career advice or
just support for those
minority researchers entering the cancer disparities field in
these times?
I'll take the second one.
Well, we've been going.
And then you can jump in on that one, too.
Don't give up. Okay. Just use different words, but keep doing
what you're doing in cancer disparities. Don't give up.
So can I ask you for clarification?
You mentioned policy change for HPV.
What are you talking about for that specifically?
Well, just the discourse about the change of age and
expanding the age range.
It already is up to 45.
But when we talked about the younger age, I don't know if that-
Nine to 45.
Is it viable to like-
Bill says, and he's correct, there has to be a study done to demonstrate that.
Sure.
That's not a policy. That's funding to do a study
to determine if it should be like newborn
vaccination and if the age should be younger than nine.
That would have to be a study is what he's talking about, not necessarily a policy
change.
Sure.
But keep doing what you're doing. Watch your words, but
keep doing what you're doing because those communities need you.
Keep the faith.
Yep.
The one other thing I would say, exactly what they said.
The science may not be used now, but it is going to be eventually used.
So whatever you do, keep collecting the scientific evidence.
Policy change cannot happen without scientific evidence to support it.
So that's really important to remember.
Mm-hmm.
Well, and I think all of us in research and in academia have a
passion for what we're doing, and we're doing it for a reason.
We could all probably make more money or become more famous if we spend our time
elsewhere. So what-
What about you, Tim?
No, I would never be more famous or rich, no matter what I did. Yeah.
But
I think that if you have a passion for what you do,
you're going to be successful and you're going to
dedicate yourself to it. If you don't love it, why are you doing it in the first
place? So keep figuring out what you love and how you're going to
make your own impact and be true to yourself.
That's just, I think, what we all try to do.
Okay.
So I have a question about how we establish risk factors and then
policies surrounding those. So obviously we're seeing birth code trends around
increasing colon, uterus, pancreas, a number of other
cancers. We've set the bar so high
to establish causation of an environmental factor, and then
also for once we identify an environmental factor, for actually
enacting policies around those, whether it's diet related or a chemical.
So I'm just wondering what the panel's thoughts are about how we could change
things, especially leveraging more modern science.
Everybody's eligible on this.
I
think there's not one answer to your question.
So for example, epidemiological data was sufficient to
get people to stop smoking, to make a surgeon general's report.
We didn't need to know the mechanism of smoking-related carcinogenesis to
do that, so...
Do a randomized control trial.
Right. Or do a randomized trial. We were able to take certain kinds
of evidence because the impact was sufficiently high that we could
make a policy decision. That's not the case for most of the other things that we're
doing, and so it's going to really vary what kind of level of evidence is going to
be impacted on the
area under the curve kind of computations and
what interventions might be able to be used to minimize,
mitigate that risk. And so I don't know that there's one answer to your question
except that
we did it with smoking. We're not probably going to use that same paradigm for most
of the risk factors we have.
Let me add something.
You want to add something?
About the science of this, okay? So
theRandomized
controlled trials are useful in a certain setting, okay?
But I would say weak
risk factors, you're never going to show it in a randomized controlled trial.
And that was some of our early mistakes.
We spent a huge amount of money trying to verify something.
But people will come to me and say: "What do you think about nutrition and cancer
risk?" And I say, "Yeah, it's absolutely related," but do we need a randomized
control trial to show it? No. No.
Because you should be eating healthier because we already know that it helps your
cardiovascular risk, right? So we have to be thoughtful about where we make
those investments in research and recognize that
weak effects are almost impossible to show in a randomized controlled trial
because randomized controlled trials are not perfect either. Yeah. Okay?
So there's going to be different kinds of evidence-
And too many additional variables.
Right. So there's different kinds of evidence that are appropriate.
Tim's example, Peto and Doll showing that then led to a whole bunch
of other evidence
because it was such a strong risk factor that it was
incredible, right? To be honest, we didn't need a
randomized control trial necessarily for HPV testing in the United
States. We saw it in Kaiser data when people were co-tested with HPV and
cytology. HPV was the driver. That's what shifted the FDA.
So there's not one size fits all in
terms of the evidence. But I would say weak effects are almost impossible to
verify.
And that's not the things that make a difference. Right.
And weak effects are going to be hard to make policy around because... Yeah.
Do you have something you want to add?
Yeah, I'd just like to add, respectfully, what Tim said, that,
yes, epidemiological trials showed that there was a relationship between smoking
and cancer, but we have not solved the problem.
Oh, no.
Because we haven't managed to... An average smoker quits something
like 30 times before they actually quit.
And we haven't put all the facilities or the processes in place to
make sure that we support them to stop using.
So that's what I was mentioning when I talked about complacency.
We kind of assume it's there. We've been doing it for 30 years.
We've solved the problem. That's not true. We haven't solved the problem.
It was more than 100 years ago that Mark Twain famously said, "What's all the
fuss about smoking and stopping smoking?
I've done it myself 100 times."
Right.
Last two.
Hi. Marian Hajduch, Czech Republic, Palacky University and
Czech Ministry of Health.
It's fantastic panel, and I wanted to share our experience from our
country. I heard a lot of about the reimbursement problems
you have in the US.
We have a different problem, actually the opposite, on the Wild East,
which is that we have 100% coverage of all
preventive screening programs and 100% coverage of
all follow-up tests and medications from the public health
insurance. And still, we have much
lower coverage of the target
population than you have in the US.
Mm-hmm.
So the coverage itself is not the solution.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
It's actually more complicated problem.
And I think that have a full coverage without
understanding the value, because the problem we have is that
people do not understand the value of the screening.
And this is critical aspect. And they think that if
it's for free, it's most probably doesn't have a value.
So,
to find a proper balance in the coverage and
in the understanding the value in the population, I think this
is the key to attract more people into the screening programs.
Thank you.
Right. I think it's just like with the HPV vaccine.
It wasn't implemented correctly, so implementation is the key.
And how you implement a program in the US is totally different than how you're
going to implement it in the Czech Republic.
And so that's why you have to start with some qualitative research where you
talk to the people,
the consumers, you talk to the health systems, you talk to the providers,
and you understand what the barriers are and the facilitators.
And then there are tons of evidence-based interventions published
that you can pick and choose from and adapt to the setting
and then implement that.
There's a lot of messaging, a lot of different things that could be done.
But just because you build it does not mean they're going to come.
Okay. Final question.
Wait, just one point on this. The reason why Australia was successful with
HPV vaccination, they spent over a year
socializing HPV vaccination before it was FDA approved, before it was
introduced. They did their boots on the ground
engagement
on the people they were trying to help long before they started to put needles in
arms.
Yeah. I agree. Thank you.
Go ahead.
Hi, thank you for the panelists, and very appreciation.
And I'm Sophia from City of Hope, the lung cancer screening and
tobacco cessation program. I'm also part of the
Moonshot CGI
program for tobacco cessation. So,
besides patient navigator, I'm also a big advocate for community
health workers. They know the community the best, and
especially in California, a very diverse community.
We really need that reimbursement for the community health worker.
So given that strong evidence
linking to tobacco, nicotine, alcohol
to multiple cancers, so how should
policy makers require this industry to
financially support the cancer health
screening, not just beyond lung cancer, right?And also like
related cancers such as pancreatic, head and neck,
stomach cancer,
we have tons of evidence, right? ACR already saying that
the tobacco is one of the leading cause of many types of cancer.
So besides
of the
tobacco cessation and how can we
hold them accountable, maybe to pay for, right?
We ask the question, who's going to pay for it?
Like for the cancer screening and also cancer prevention.
Okay.
Thank you.
Go for it.
Yeah, it's a great
comment. And if we think about
more than 20 years ago, the multiple lawsuits against the
tobacco industry with
huge
settlements. And in the state of Washington, I fought to try
to have the Washington State settlement be directed to
healthcare.
And of course, it got gobbled up by the legislature and
regular state financing budgets.
And it would be nice if
we could direct the taxes of
alcohol and tobacco to the place where they have
consequences, like you're bringing up, healthcare, but that
I think a problem that we have in reducing,
for example,
tobacco dependence is the fact that our governments
have a benefit of tobacco use because of taxes
that they collect.
So
that is a political problem. And so I don't have a
solution for that. The problem that I think is
in trying to improve access is
a separate issue of simplification.
And in lung cancer, the one that I'm the expert
in, we've made it too complicated, and that is
a barrier to access and uptake.
And
I'm the chair of the NCCN Lung Cancer Guideline Panel, and a
big effort that we've had is to simplify and make it
pragmatic and purposefully imperfect.
If we try to make things perfect, to try to
avoid
somebody from lower risk slipping into cancer screening,
then we've eliminated 10 people that could have had cancer
screening that needed it.
So that's a separate issue than the one that you brought up, but
a point that I've tried to make with policy makers
in trying to be willing to be less perfect
in order to broaden the gates that we can get people
in for screening that can benefit from screening.
That's a great point. Yeah.
So
one thing I want to add is,
so you know the master settlement agreement that we are all discussing with the
tobacco industry was really meant to support
cessation services and health services for people.
That was the goal when the settlement was made and when they
argued it in court and the tobacco industry were providing monies to support
this. Did it go towards this issue? No.
It's really pitiful when you look at some of the states in terms of how much money
actually went towards this. And one of the things I have learned, which I didn't
really realize, is you have to be involved as a researcher in every step
of the policymaking and legislative process.
So some states in the US did a really nice
job of specifying upfront how they were going to use that
money. And they set up systems which allowed them to use it that way.
That was maybe one or two states, California being one of them.
But most of the other states didn't set up any good regulations at all.
So that money is just being used for a variety of other things.
So I guess my point is, it's a lot more work for us as a scientific
community. Unfortunately, there are only so many hours in the day.
But I think following each step of the process and providing input,
going to legislative sessions in your state, going to things like that
and testifying is super important.
Okay, well, I think that's a good close.
We've had a terrific session.
Kudos to all the speakers, kudos to the audience, and
especially those of you who stayed to the end.
And we really had good questions and excellent responses and quite a broad
array of issues that we need to bring to bear on this very important
domain. Thank you all.